[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition and we've
got a
really juicy topic today we're talking
about
game changers in their athletic events
by having introduced a technique that
was without precedent
thereby changing the game so i've got
with me as usual my co-host chuck knight
what's up neil all right good and you're
here for
levity because you've never done any
professional sports at all i've never
done anything
any sports at all perry
so just so there's just to manage
expectations of the audience that's
awesome
and we got gary o'reilly of course gary
we love you man love you too neil
all right all right uh we we stole you
from the uk
uh where you were a soccer pro and a
soccer announcer and now you're
helping us here with star talk yeah and
when i played professional
soccer i did on occasion make people
laugh but that's another story
and a whole other whole other cause of
humor
anything chuck nice would be giving us
so here's what we're gonna do the this
this is the first
in a sort of a mini series uh sort of a
subset
of star talk sports edition where
we're gonna include a salute to
science and technology okay
and it's it's how these things have come
to bear
on sports that were long traditional but
then were transformed
simply in the presence of clever
technique
clever technologies uh and innovative
science and for this particular show
we've got my friend and long time
colleague charles liu
charles hi neil good to see you and at
people who know you know you from this
show you're our resident uh how do we
call it
chuck chief geek in chief you're our
geek in chief because on the geek
spectrum you know i
i fancy myself on the geek spectrum okay
i'm there
and i'm i'm i'm the but yeah what we
know
you're in the visible light
you're in the visible light because
because the interesting thing about
geekdom is no matter how geeky you think
you are
the scale just keeps going beyond and
you'll come up with something and that
you're proud of and someone just walks
in knocks on the door and say nope
you missed out episode seven in the
third comic book of the second
and it's like damn and all you can do is
stand in awe
as we all do for you by the way that's
also
true for opera just so you know is that
right
yeah the see you you just proved our
picture
you can't help yourself you just proved
opera buffs are amazing they think you
can pull out like one italian phrase in
some opera written in 1864 by somebody
that you've never heard of
and you just thought you were really
good at it and you're just not it's just
cause somebody else just just throws
down on top of that
so we just we just found out like on the
spectrum charles is gamma-ray
so charles you are a um you're
my co-author on more than one project uh
you were around
as one of our chief scientists when we
built the rose center for earth and
space
yes um you go way back um you're now on
you on the faculty are you now dean or
something you got some high falutin
academic title at the um just just a
professor just a professional okay
you're just a plain old professor
okay uh and you uh physics and in the
department of physics there
physics in astronomy physics and
astronomy at the college of staten
island of the city university of new
york
and that's in re arms reach of us which
wouldn't be necessary
in covert times but when you have we
have you in studio that helps
because we call on you often so what do
we want to do we want to
introduce um i'm going to go in sequence
here we have several athletes that we're
profiling in a good way charles charles
overreacts anytime something like that
right
we're profiling simone biles and he's
saying why you always go
i was going to i'm i'm i was about to
react i'm like
i'm not a big fan of profiling that's
all i'm saying that's what i'm saying
too
okay so she's the reigning and
undisputed queen
of world gymnastics okay and she has
more
world championship medals than any other
gymnast and
so here's what she did she raised the
bar
on difficulty and technique
while basically gracefully demonstrating
how physics can be exploited to
annihilate your opponents
okay physics don't argue with physics
because physics is going to show up and
it's either going to help you or knock
you out of
competition so why don't we start out uh
i have a clip of her in 2019
u.s gymnastics championships where she
made history by being the first woman to
land a
triple double in her floor routine
and let's let's let's let's hear this
commentary
from was this uh nbc uh nbc
sports announcers uh giving commentary
on what they witnessed let's check this
out
it is unreal and as well done as
anybody man or woman has competed in
here we go right off the bat the very
first tumbling pass
triple twisting double back
[Music]
money just keep making history simone
biles
well so uh first
charles how does a human body do this
what's what's going on here and could it
be
that she's four feet eight i mean i i
don't remember many
six feet gymnast of of any gender
so what's going what's going on here
well as always
it's gravity and rotation that makes the
difference gravity
restricts the amount of time simone has
in the air
to perform the stunts and the techniques
but that's true for everybody so don't
be telling me yeah that's helping her in
some way well
if she can push harder and get higher
then she can have longer to do her work
hang time right
that's the hang time and then right
rotation is the other aspect
she's doing both a twist and she's doing
a roll or flip
right so she has to be able to torque
her body
in two different axes at the same time
triple twisting
double flip right it is truly an amazing
combination well let's just unpack this
so in physics you learn about rotation
right so a wheel
turns and there's one axis and then the
equation's related to that
but she's not turning on just one axis
that's right
so she has to minimize her
rotational inertia or moment of inertia
as it's sometimes called
in two axes at once and we have a hard
time thinking about that but
uh we'll get to figure skating later i
think but if you watch a figure skater
start a spin they'll start with their
arms out
and then as they pull their arms in
closer and closer to the centers of
their bodies their spin and goes faster
and faster and faster
that has to do with the conservation of
angular momentum just as you described
in order for simone to be able to twist
three times and flip twice
while in the air her axes have to be
super tight in both directions and this
is for example why a six-foot gymnast
doesn't do as well as a four foot eight
gymnast because
if you're big it's really hard to
compact yourself in every dimension that
you can
in order to do the rotation i don't know
i don't think you've ever seen shaquille
o'neal do a floor routine that would be
nice
you guys are amazing that's amazing
awesome yeah so
with shaquille o'neal accepted here
just in this example
do we really want to see shaq do a floor
routine really
i was just i closed my eyes and i said
no no exactly
i think at the end it wouldn't be a
floor right it'd be a serious
hit it's just right yeah series of
craters
crater routine the crater routine so
so charles so for an ice skater because
the friction is so low
between them and the they and the ice
as as they're spinning they can spin
faster and obviously
if you're in midair there's no friction
not to speak of between you and the air
so you get to spin faster in the same
way this figure skaters do
whereas if i'm just standing on the
ground and i pull my arms in i don't end
up spinning faster because
the friction is still actually new i
don't think we should get shaquille
o'neal could do that
ask him standing on the ground sometime
ask shaquille
okay maybe maybe on his tippy toes to
swing around with his arms open oh
ballet style yeah and pull the arms in
and you will spin faster
you'll stop really quickly because of
the friction but you still will go
faster for a short period of time
so so simone bios has to do this in two
axes
the twist and the flipping so do though
do you want those
axes to come together like so that
what are they called like those oh man
like a gyroscope what
what are those things called there well
gyroscope is a gyroscopic effect is you
have to spin very very fast
so this is not exactly what we're
talking about but the spinning is still
the same
right the concept is the same if you're
spinning along one axis and you're
spinning along another axis
that's right ideally right the axis of
rotations if they
intersect right you want that
to be the same spot whichever direction
you're going
right to minimize the amount of torque
you need to go in either direction
yeah so so what you're saying is
if you're if you manage to spin in two
axes
but they but
those two axes will intersect only in
one spot so what's wrong with that
there's there's of course to say they
intersect in the same spot if they
intersect they intersect that is the
spot
so what are you saying right so i'm
saying is let's say you uh
okay by the way when charles says that's
what he's pointing to that means he says
he was wrong
okay
thanks neil you're you are assuming that
the axes are on the same plane
right when you have two lines in the
same plane they must intersect at a
single point in euclidean geometry
but i'm thinking in three dimensions
which means that you might be offset
okay you have to do this and do that i
just got out geeked there right
now wait when you say my bad does that
mean that you're admitting that you're
wrong
yes i'm admitting that i'm wrong not
only but me wrong saying you're wrong
don't mess with those gamma-ray geeks
where is she getting all of this energy
to perform this and
get her hang time because when she does
her flicks she doesn't seem to have her
hands in contact with the floor for
any length of time and it's not as if
she's taking a
100-yard run-up to get the swelling she
does take
she does take a run-up but to get to the
corner right it's it's only like
you know one half the diagonal length of
the floor
but in addition the spring action that
she gets off the ground
has to come from her muscle power mostly
from her lower body
but even from her upper body she can
produce a little bit
by swinging her arms or otherwise
lifting the upper carriage of her body
and that vertical push is so important
if you get your body up two feet off the
ground
to go from up and back down again
you have about seven tenths of a second
here on earth's surface
wow if you can get four feet off the
ground you have a full second
and if you get six feet off the ground
you have 1.2
seconds give or take so if i can get my
body six feet off the ground
i am using a ladder yeah me
too the crane and the grapple hook
yeah i'm gonna walk to the edge of a six
foot high ledge that's how i get about
2.6 feet off the ground there's there's
no vertical way for me to do it
but if you look at her video of
how high she gets with that spring she
looks like she gets at least four feet
off the ground i wouldn't be surprised
if it was closer to six feet
and you can time the time that she
leaves the floor till the time she
hits the floor again well you know she's
four feet
long you know she's four feet eight so
it looks like she leaps higher than
not to the bottom of her feet but when
she's tumbling forward
it looks like she's easily arcing higher
than her own height
yes that's what it looks like to me
that's right and so every
fraction of a second gives her that much
more time to complete a twist or a flip
so uh it's a tremendous physical
activity
so it might mean that the future of
floor exercises
in competitors is to continue to improve
that hang time
it just gives you more time to do things
to get points for that's right what is
the acceleration you can get
off the ground before you perform your
mid-air
activities smaller gymnasts have that
advantage but the smaller you are
possibly the less muscle mass you have
and thus the less power you can generate
when you leap and so it's a trade-off
and technique is so important in this
case i'm sure
because of the balance of those two
competing
characteristics well i've got one more i
got another clip here
uh speaking of technique uh there's the
one and only kareem abdul-jabbar
all right and i'd sat down with him a
couple of years ago
and we chatted about what what became
the most
lethal basketball shot in the nba
and by the way of course he's six-time
nba champion six-time
mvp but he hasn't played for like 32
years but his point total career point
total
is still unsurpassed after 32 years a
third of a century people
so and but some people remember him as
starring opposite bruce lee
in game of death game of death my
favorite moment
so my favorite moment is when he kicks
bruce lee in the chest and bruce because
bruce lee is a tiny man
and bruce lee looks and there's a huge
footprint on the chest
absolutely and of course he was bringing
that bright neon
jumpsuit at that time yeah so it was
totally it was all there
so the question in my conversation with
him was what does he even understand
of his own about the skyhook that he
pioneered check it out
what percent of your 38 000 points were
skyhook
points would you guess i'd say three
quarters
three quarters yeah but you know i
learned
everything i learned you know had to do
with learning the mechanics of the shot
and shooting a bow and arrow
because she figure out what the drop is
all about
you know what the arc is all about and
once you get got that figured out you
can
you become accurate you're a marksman
at that point so you're a basketball
marksman
you have to be well if you're going to
be successful you know
and i led the league in field goal
percentage a number of years
i think that was really my success too
you know i had a successful shot that
they couldn't block it
that's what enabled me to endure what's
intriguing about
this hook shot i think bill bradley
famously was quoted
saying that in the hookshot because he
also did the hook shot
the hook shot your eyes are not on the
ball or on your hand
or anywhere near your arm so that
there's a
sense of where the basket is relative to
the ball
if you have enough experience on the
court so you don't actually need to look
at where the basket is
and you must agree with that because you
were successful in the coke shot you
don't have to
know where the ball is you got to keep
your eye on the basket
but you don't have to have your eye on
the ball okay but that requires some
musculoskeletal
connectivity yes that's why you practice
that's the quote of the interview
i just like it's that you know the
person scores thirty two point thousand
points so yeah just keep your eye on the
basket and the ball finds the bet
he's casually talking about this and
this is
extreme high precision accuracy in that
shot
and and his talent so charles it we
didn't mention the fact that he happens
to be seven feet two
yeah so so how good is he on an uneven
parallel bar
chuck you can't shake the image of shaq
out on
i just want to see a basketball player
do gymnastics now
[Music]
so charles he's almost shooting down
at the basket that's right well part of
the reason the skyhook was so
devastating
was that if he lifts his arms up and
jumps vertically
the ball at the top of the arc is above
the level of the rim
and so he's able to drop the ball in
such a way that the
cross section that the ball has on the
way down
is maximized and nobody can defend
against him
because according to the rules you
cannot slap the ball
on the way if it's on the way down oh my
gosh that's right because then it's
it's so quick because what's it called
if you do that it's a gold standard
goaltending
right and it's an automatic basket so if
kareem is doing the skyhook
unless he misses nobody can defend
against it that's why it was
the only shot in basketball to be
determined an
indefensible shot because the only way
you can get to it
is to block it while it's
basically at his hand it's still in his
hand well i think it's only been done
once
yeah you just have to jump ten feet up
to right yeah you know it's just not fun
yeah now now michael jordan's fadeaway
jumper was also claimed to be
indefensible but for a different reason
he created
space while he was shooting but somebody
who was like nine feet
tall could theoretically have stopped
that shot but for kareem it was
literally
not allowed wow so did players stop
being seven foot two did the physical
appeals
right did the physics change why on
earth don't we see the sea
still see the skyhook in the nba
because you now have steph curry
who has raised an entire generation
of kids who want to shoot the ball from
their bedroom
so that that was cool and
get all net along the way rule changes
rule changes and style changes are the
only reason
i think that it's not uh fashionable
anymore aside from the fact that kareem
was a
as you described neil a remarkable uh
human
uh in terms of musculoskeletal things
going on right right
i don't know if anybody has that sign of
hand-eye coordination we don't even have
to look at the ball
to drop it into the hoop from the
distance this the three-point shot now
is statistically more devastating than
any two-point shooting
uh unfortunately if you're good at it
but if you're good at it over time
if you're good at the three points right
and the thing is though if
three i forget who said this three
always beats two
three is greater than two that's right
and three is great thank you chuck for
that little bit of arithmetic for this
show guys we got to take a quick break
gotta take a quick break when we come
back more
in our exploration of athletic greatness
as measured by who has changed the game
just by their very existence when we
return
we're back star talk sports edition i've
got
with me our resident geek and chief and
you know who that is
me
then you woke up and that was give you
the crown gary go for it oh yeah it's
it's not to be taken from you sir of
course we've got gary and chuck we're
talking about
athletic greatness that manifests not
simply by how hard they work but what
technique they might have perfected and
we can't have a show like this without
talking about the 1968 mexico city
olympics
a lot of interesting things happened
there not the least of which
was bob beeman breaking the long jump
world record why more than a foot
by more than a foot and that would test
him for steroids
because that's a lot
so a bit more than a foot and
it was he didn't just lightly beat his
own record
he smashed his own record and every
other jump that had ever
made so interesting things happened in
those olympics and i remember i was old
enough to
to to remember them uh mexico city it
was it was at high altitude and all this
but for the purposes of this
show we're going to talk about dick
fosberry
he's a high jumper and he won the gold
medal
going backwards over the bar
when everyone before him had gone
forwards over the bar
and it looks like he just flops
backwards into the
into the cushion and it became known as
the fosberry flop
so we've got this clip of an announcer
sort of
introducing the viewer to dick
fosberry's
innovative technique and it's got this
very
period flavor to it check it out
an amazing and amusing champion is dick
fosberry
here seen psyching himself to a winning
pitch
[Music]
and another gold medal what's that again
dick
unorthodox perhaps but kids all over the
world
are sure to be trying the famous
fosberry flop
god i love you just it's it's just
amazing how those
how you can tell this is what you had to
sound like in order to be an announcer
back then
that was you needed that announcer voice
gary that people sound like did people
sound like that in uk
sports broadcasting too back in the 60s
um the language is the same the accent's
slightly different so it was
it was very formulaic we've copied so
so charles tell me why uh why does this
work
and why does everyone do it okay well
two key things
uh people used to go forward or
backward over the bar right if you jump
backwards
or sideways there was a scissors kick
technique
where you actually could get slightly
higher kick
off some felt going backwards or
sideways
then going forward but what fosbury did
was go over backwards but bent
right he never needed to bring his
entire center of mass
over the bar all he was had to do was to
make sure that every part of his body
was over the bar for at least a brief
moment
and so he could fluidly go over
backwards
and because the legs could hang down low
he didn't have to produce as much upward
power and then he could land with a flop
on his back and his head so what you're
saying is if you go over backwards your
legs
dangle at your knees that creates part
of an arc
and any good athlete is flexible bending
backwards
right and so you he makes it like a a
semi circle
out of his body going backwards and then
curls over the bar
but what you're telling me all of us is
that he took his center of mass outside
of his body
basically right think of a u-shape right
if you have a if you have a bar and it's
straight the center of mass is in the
middle
but if you make a u-shape the center of
mass is kind of down
in the middle of the u so if you're
going over and the whole time
compared to the bar you're a u-shape
then your center of mass
rides below the bar at all times you
know the funny thing is
you would think this would be intuitive
because he's really just following
the natural curve of the human body
from our spine all the way down to our
ankles our body
curves that way but if you were to go
forward at some point the curve stops at
your thigh
because your knees don't bend they don't
bend the other way
you would think somebody would have
thought of this before him
do you know what chuck if you introduce
thicker matting into the equation which
it came around around about that sort of
time
you can exercise that technique if
you've got nothing but sand to jump into
over a bar
your landing's quite brutal that's an
excellent point the technology
or the rule change that allowed a
mattress
right gary i mean before this that
people landed on a
sort of like you said a sand pit or a
thin mattress or something but once they
created those really springy thick
things
you didn't mind hitting the back of your
head every time you landed
and so maybe people thought of it before
but that said i actually want to keep
the brain
so the guy who actually thought of it
got brain damaged
he thought of it and did it right he did
it got four concussions
he forgot who he was and the technique
was temporarily lost
all right so charles the world record
now for men's um
sotomayor from cuba yeah all right it's
eight feet
and a quarter inch that is huge and the
women's record
uh costa de nova from bulgaria six
feet ten and a quarter inches wow this
is
i i can't even imagine this but let me
ask you
is there of course they're all doing the
fosberry flop is there some bit of
physics
that we're waiting to be invented to
make a a brilliant leap in these numbers
jetpack
was the fosbury flock the physics limit
of this of this
event well i imagine that there
could be technique further developed in
the future
that allows you to go
higher without producing more power
and that might require a human being
adapting
training in a different way different
muscles something like that okay so a
different uh
leaping technique right and every time
every time people say oh we've reached
the limit you can't do any better
somebody eventually breaks that limit so
i
it would be foolish for me to speculate
whether we've reached the top okay let's
let's let's join two of our game
changers together here what if i got
myself that six foot gym nest
and made them do a floor routine run up
and get them up and over the bar
would oh wow interesting that would be
amazing and then the landing would have
to be
really far right and then do that huge
jump
i think that would be a really
interesting thing to probably be against
the laws of the event
but i'm i'm interested to see if that
experiment works
rule changes would make a great point
gary just like the three-point play
put the sky hook into the back burner of
basketball
let's join my clip with edwin moses we
had him on star talk recently
uh he's an olympic double gold medalist
and
his event is the 400 meter hurdles and
by the way
he was a physics and engineering major
at morehouse college
yes
he had an unbeaten streak of nine years
nine months and nine days
who figured that one out i don't know
what that is but we want to how did he
do it let's find out
check it out all i had to do was teach
myself how to run
the hurdles 35 meters apart and the
first time i did it i found myself
running 13
i found myself uh using my left leg
which is the inner leg
13 strides between her steps yeah yeah
running closer to the curve and then i
figured out that if i run
eight inches away from the inner line
which is where they measure the lane
versus uh you know two or three feet in
the middle of the lane i'm saving
three to four meters per race which is
like 15 feet
anywhere from 12 to 15 feet so that was
the first adjustment i made
wait wait edwin are you saying that the
effective
length of your path because you start
out
in blocks right right and
of course you have to stay in your lane
because that you were hurdle all the way
around
so the length the actual 400 meters
is not the center line of the width of
your lane eight inches
eight inches from the inner line i
didn't know that eight inches from the
inner line so my endeavor was to run as
close to as that
as close to the inner line as i could
whereas most people just
run all over the lane and by doing that
i calculated the radius of the track and
figured it out that i was saving three
to four meters per race so that's 12 15
feet
and i was i was basically that
i just love the fact that edwin moses
ran all those races with a ruler
strapped to his foot
with the laser altimeter
[Laughter]
no so this is so charles
talk me through this so um
is it really that i mean i have to
believe he did the calculation right but
but can i get a backup verification of
that from you let's do some real-time
math shall we
uh if we approximate the oval track as a
circle
and the 400 meters is all the way around
yeah okay the circumference of anything
is
2 pi r where r is the radius
so you're going around the whole track
once 2 pi r now if r
happens to be say three feet less
or two feet less in this case it's like
one and a half feet less right
so it's two times pi times one and a
half feet one and a half
two six right so one and a half times
six something is about nine or ten feet
he got it
bang on so what we're saying is he ran a
shorter race right you did
that's it i mean think about it ten feet
is considered a
massive advantage okay so if he doesn't
tell anyone this and everyone say oh my
gosh look at this
amazing athlete he's just smarter than
everybody else
that's right well yeah i mean all track
people uh do know that in the end you
want to get on the inside
right that that people know but the
question
is uh exactly how much uh
edwin was able to do the math quite
literally
and then and so this for all of you kids
listening
and you're like doing math and going
when am i ever going to use this
crap when you win a gold medal
that's right that's right when you're
undefeated for nine
years nine months and nine days but
another thing that you should uh
note in here is what he said the 13
steps
uh in his day very few people could even
do 13. most people struggled at 15 and
the more you touch the ground the more
you slow down
right if you stay in the air more so if
you only touch the ground 13 times
between
hurdles you have a distinct advantage
over people who are
15 times touching is this is this true
charles for the
for the embarrassingly obvious fact that
whenever you're touching the ground
you're not moving forward
if your foot is in contact with the
track your foot is not moving forward
correct this your center of mass
continues to move but
you will be moving a smaller distance if
a piece of view is touching the ground
just because of the friction
you're also you're adding the vertical
and the horizontal push the force every
time you touch the ground so that's how
you could run yeah you could conceivably
uh
run with more power with each step but
chuck you're right cheetahs like take a
step and they're like
gliding through the air for a period of
time right and they purposely elongate
their body while they're
in the air in the air to cover more
distance and so that
they're touching the ground much less
yeah
chuck you're saying the cheetah did the
math
well soccer players too right gary
soccer players do that right
if you want to do a truly high speed run
you are trying to take as few strides as
possible and make them long
right yeah but that's if but if you have
the ball you need to still control the
ball and then that's the opposite
that's the alchemy to be able to run
with the ball as quick as you can run
without it that's why
messi is so great because he
doesn't have those long strides but he's
so
fast with the dribble yep absolutely
so charles in the modern day tracks they
use the tartan sort of rubber
track that has a sort of a springiness
to it tell me briefly about that
briefly because we got some more we want
to cover okay well the elasticity of
that stuff is certainly very nice and
being able to provide a little extra
spring in your step every time you step
down
but really that elastic stuff is to
protect your ankles
more important than anything else you
want to keep the runners running for a
longer period of time in their lives so
they're like shock absorbers so in a
sense you get an advantage but everyone
gets the same advantage because they're
all running on the same track
but maybe you get an extra year or two
in your career without
pounding it hard well wait so that's
first wait wait
but a shock absorber absorbs shocks
if your energy that you use to squeeze
it returns to you
with the material recovering its shape
then it's a
shock uh helper in a sense
right and what it does is the parts of
your body that need to
compress like your ankles okay will
compress
and be able to come back out you're
reducing you're
reducing the impulse that your shock
your ankles are feeling because the
amount of time of impact
is increased by this time it takes to
squish you know the other aspect to
the vulcanized rubber the mondo track
that they run on
you use shorter spikes if they ran on
cinders the spikes had to be longer
because they wanted grip
the grip means friction the shorter
spikes
don't have as much friction and moses
said as soon as he ran in the first
his first olympics and he realized he
was going to run on this rubberized
track
he went game over everyone else is
running for second place
right because my father when he ran
track um when i was a little kid and he
still ran i saw
his cleats and and spikes and
when the tartan tracks came in and other
tracks of that nature
he was able to use the shorter spike and
yeah the less time you've dug into the
track to your point charles um you want
to minimize how much time you're doing
that
wow guys we got another clip but we ran
out of time in this segment let's get to
it in our shoot the [ __ ] segment
um and we're gonna talk about sasha
cohen the figure skater who
did a quad jump oh like how when and
where
and we're gonna get to that right when
we come back on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition
third segment final segment
usually we just shoot the [ __ ] here but
there was so much content some of it
spilled into this segment
let's get straight to it we're going to
talk about the figure skater sasha cohen
who's actually a friend of star talk she
appeared in one of our live
performances at the brooklyn academy of
music it was great to have her on stage
and
she still has bubbly energy and it was
great just talking to her about
her career and what she's doing now but
let's ju let's pick up
a segment from that conversation
where we talk about how you break down
the components of the quad jump let's
check it out
huge gave a brilliant description of how
you
give yourself rotational inertia
okay for a jump we haven't even gotten
to the spin
but however you didn't well okay so
i to me in physics you generally break
things apart
into components and you put them all
together for the one thing i break this
apart
you told me how you gain spin but you
have if you're gonna do a quad
you have to be airborne long enough
to complete the quad before you hit the
ground yes
so that's part of it because you'll
notice if you've watched figure skating
this past olympics
you will see some people barely get off
the ice and they can do three turns
and some people get this this high up
and they don't complete it two or three
feet off the ice
so it really is the rotation how fast
yourself up gotcha and then obviously it
goes into like what's your body type do
you have like wide hips how fast are you
spinning
and that's why men rotate faster and
generally do a lot more quads than women
do
they're they spin faster they've got
narrower hips um
but you know women are more flexible so
we've got better spirals
how many women have done quads you know
a couple have done it in practice
and i feel like maybe like one uh one or
two have done it in competition and
you've done a quad
i have a long time ago a long time ago
you can it's thankfully youtube exists
and it will always live there
[Laughter]
that's such great memories being on
stage with her
so so charles so she said a lot of what
you said earlier in this show where you
need the height so the hang time
you could borrow from basketball and but
she's also talking about the the
diameter
the hip diameter of men versus women why
should that matter here
well um the wider you are compared to
how tall you are
the greater your uh so-called moment of
inertia
is and the more force you need in order
to get yourself spinning
so uh a man's ratio of the width of the
hip bones the pelvis
to height is smaller than a woman's
typically
on average yeah i was going to say
because that that you
you just described the antithesis to my
body type
i'm i am very hippy but my hips don't
lie so
i don't
[Laughter]
so i see what you did there so this the
speed
that she was talking about right is very
true because in figure skating you can
start your spin
while you're still on the ice so you can
create more torque so if you're speeding
along and being able to translate more
of that
translational momentum into angular
momentum as you lift off you don't have
to get as high
if you're already spinning quickly when
you start
your jump but this is
this is the really fine line for me
because if i go too fast
i'm in trouble because every jump and
chuck taught me this every jump
has to land on one foot yeah one escape
that's that's this that's a rule yes
right so if i come too
quickly i have less chance of control
and i've really got to get this fine
line and i can imagine
it's difficult if you think you're
approaching that
that jump too quickly what you might
bail out of it and just do a triple
there might be all sorts of in-event
just things that you have adjustments
yeah that you feel
in the moment before you can do that or
you just say
yes so charles what do you say about
someone who
let's say you can do it in practice but
in the in the heat of the moment
um you make mid-course decisions
regarding it yeah how how common is that
do you think
it happens uh there are athletes who
can land quads in practice but do not
land quads in competition
or others who for example have won many
uh smaller events uh world championships
even
but in the olympics have not won and the
biggest stage
yeah it's a combination of bad luck and
some sports psychology right there's
minute to minute or competition and
competition your body's just a little
bit different
the conditions might be a little bit
different and then
what your brain does to command
your body to perform these physically
very difficult acts can vary from one
venue to the next and
because it's really remarkable charles i
don't think people
pause and reflect on this often or
deeply enough
but here i am training right and i'm i'm
doing my best and i go through in
smaller contests
then i go to a big stage as is so often
the case in the olympics that's the
biggest stage there is
and then you perform better than you
ever did right well how does that happen
unless your brain
took over at some point because your
your muscles your speed your
coordination
is performing in a way you have never
seen that's cause you're an attention
[ __ ]
no no no no thank you for that analysis
yeah yeah it's just like
that's true look at that like you have
us it happens
like well but but all i'm trying to say
is that if your body
could actually do that reliably you
would be doing it all the time and the
olympics would just be
another day in the park but it's not
it's a social challenge for those who do
rise to the challenge
it's got to be the brain not the muscles
yeah that's all
from my side of it there are some people
you put them in the big game their big
game player arrives
and that like reggie jackson being mr
october yeah and it's
it you know i think you're absolutely
right when it becomes a mental aspect
because
they didn't all of a sudden become the
hulk
this thing happened inside their mind
and they just said right it's time to
deliver
whatever the best is is coming now right
well we all know that our brains control
how much say
adrenaline goes into our systems and
allows our bodies to perform a little
bit higher or lower
for some people well so she just gave me
an idea
so if at the beginning of a sprint race
or anything or at any rate at all
you just have a monster chasing people
right yeah and as a matter of fact
that's how usain bolt wins
all his races right before uh they sound
the gun
he hears whoa and
he's actually there's a monster in his
head chasing him right
put put a like a cheetah behind
everybody in the starting blocks
[Laughter]
all right so so so what we're agreeing
upon here is the limits of your body
can only actually be achieved in the
limits of your mind
i love that well the two of them are
quote
the two of them are tied closely
together i don't know if it's one way or
the other that's more important but
certainly they are what's your
independence
what you just said we'll check that one
down yeah that's a new t-shirt
we're going to get that man getting that
on the t-shirt i
i heard his pro i heard this program i
was driving once and i
because i was driving i don't know the
name of the program
but it's talk it was talking about
exactly what you just said
and there's this bicycle race that lasts
for
like days and days like non-stop you
don't get to stop
and this gentleman who participated
in the race finished the race
basically in a state of unconsciousness
because
he was pushing himself so hard and his
teammates were pushing him
and he but basically it was all
his brain that was doing everything okay
so that takes us back to the original
marathon
well what's the original marathon well
as the story goes
you know the runner who was sent back to
athens from marathon
to report on the results of the battle
uh
and he ran the whole way i'm told in the
legend he
delivered the information and then
dropped dead oh
yeah that's too bad so why didn't he
drop dead one kilometer sooner
right right right so because his brain
carried himself right is the brain
carried him over
yeah isn't it true charles in china that
the
death rate of citizens senior citizens
probably
is higher the week after the chinese new
year than before
possibly yes because it could be just
they ate too much
they partied down that's interesting and
i think other holidays
it might be true like christmas and new
year's in
the united states right i mean it you
you came up with a great quote right now
but i think yogi berra said it just as
well or you know when he said that uh
yogi berra get your yogis straight yogi
berra
thank you what did i say yogi bear
oh guess what
okay fine yogi berra said it ain't over
90 percent
[Laughter]
yogi berra said you should have to pick
a dick basket okay
uh no yogi berra said 90 of the game is
half
mental what a great quote that's amazing
okay so he flunked his math class
[Laughter]
but he's in the hall of fame he and
edward moses have to like duke it out
they gotta figure that out right charles
here's a thought for you is there any
room left
for innovation in sports technique or
are we
here okay there's my answer but do we
have to go straight to machines and
and and human genetic no i don't think
so i mean
there are two aspects of this right one
is um
individual activity uh you guys remember
the burke off blastoff
yeah yeah this was a backstroker who
figured out that
that if he did not surface from his
first launch
right until he was more than halfway
across the board if he stayed a porpoise
underwater
dolphin clipped his way across halfway
and he had a devastating advantage for a
long time
and the world uh swimming competition
body
banned the movie yeah changed the rules
because they felt that it was
outside the scope of what the backstroke
was supposed to be
but did they take away his metal you
know when they did that but they didn't
want any of his awards okay well they
could have done that with fosberry
and they could have said no you broke
the rule what this
mystical rule that we don't even know
we've written yet and but they didn't
they kept it in
so is this just regressively thinking
um uh boards of the sports possibly that
won't allow innovation you can argue
that if you're underground
underwater for so long you're not
actually doing a backstroke
right you're on your back but you're not
actually on the surface that's what they
say you're violating the spirit
right of this of the stroke itself right
it depends on each game and it's but
he's still on his back
that's right come on now it really
depends you're not swinging your arms
though right
so he's still on his back didn't they
ban ryan lochte as well
for his his innovation what did he do
he did i think he did a similar thing
but he did it in the medley
so he used the similar technique in the
medley and i think they
put the kibosh on that as well yeah it's
possible that swimming just has
different
philosophical philosophy about the rules
compared to others right
and then in team sports of course if you
assemble a team of people with
extra special skills or certain
abilities you have
an infinite number of different
innovations you can do
i think of the west coast offense in
football for example uh that was created
by bill walsh and san francisco 49ers
with joe montana
they basically created the offense that
dominates
what is in football today when you had a
quarterback that could throw the ball
accurately across a wide range and just
keep moving and keep moving keep moving
and the hurry up offense in football for
example had to be
curtailed a little bit because the
offensive team was getting such an
advantage by not going to the huddle
so what you're saying charles is
we don't know what hasn't been invented
yet that could
innovate things that we think have gone
stale because you need just someone
clever to come along
and rethink it that's right so i think
the answer to gary's question is that
innovation will always continue and it's
all a matter of whether sport
can keep up and there'll always be
someone there to say
no you can't do that
guys we got to call it quits there but
this has been a very fun conversation
i'm glad we have those archival clips to
add to what we were talking about
and so chuck always good to have you
chuck nice
comment and um gary my three left feet
that'll be my twitter handle that would
be you okay
and charles lew our resident geek in
chief you you have never
failed to impress us with everything you
bring to the table
thank you and that's why we keep you in
arm's reach thank you for just us
okay all right and you had a book coming
out right the
what was that the uh the answer is in
the space travel
okay and um
there's a children's a babies book about
newton's laws of physics
excuse me for babies
and you can measure the parabolic arc of
the motion based on newton's law of
gravity
nice all right well we'll have to talk
about that one when that one
arrives but guys we're calling it quits
there uh thanks for
for this show i've been your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
keep looking up
you